in previous videos we have talked about
the idea of price elasticity and it
might have been price elasticity of
demand or price elasticity of supply but
in both situations we were talking about
our percent change in quantity over our
percent change in price if we were
talking about price elasticity of demand
it would be the percent change in
quantity demanded over the percentage
City of supply it be our percent change
in quantity supplied over a percent
change in price and as we talked about
in many videos this is a way of
measuring how sensitive is quantity
demanded or supplied to a change in
price what we're going to see in this
video is that this is not the only type
of elasticity that economists will look
at there are many types of elasticity
where they want to see how sensitive is
one thing to another for example you
could look at the percent change percent
change in labor supply so you could say
quantity of labor that would be our
labor supply divided by our percent
change in wages I'll just write it out
wages and you could view that as our
percent change in the price of labor so
you might say hey this is just a price
elasticity of supply being particularly
the labor market but you can even see
things and we'll have a whole video
about this probably my next video that I
will make where you could have the
percent change in let's say quantity is
demanded of one good divided by so let
me call it good one divided by the
percent change in price of not that good
then we would have price elasticity but
of good two and so this is actually
saying thinking about how good one is a
substitute for the other and we'll go
into a lot more depth there but the
focus of this video is you can imagine
because it was already written down
in a clean font right over here is
income elasticity and here we're gonna
think about the income elasticity of
demand and you could imagine what that
would be this is going to be our percent
change in quantity demanded demanded
divided by instead of thinking about the
percent change in price of that good or
the surface we're gonna think about the
percent change change in income of the
people who might be in the market for
that good so normally you would expect
that when our percent change in income
goes up that the same thing would happen
to our percent change in quantity
demanded for example let's say R talk
about the market for vacations well as
as my income goes up as most people's
incomes go up they might be able to
afford larger or better vacations and
that would be a normal good so this is a
situation of a normal good normal good
just is what you would expect but you
could actually have the other way around
you could imagine a situation where even
though you have an increase in your
percent change in income that does not
lead to an increase in your percent
change in quantity demanded in fact it
could lead to a decrease in the percent
change in quantity demanded or another
way of thinking about it your quantity
demanded could actually go down so you
would have a negative a negative percent
change right over here
now can you imagine any situations like
that well imagine if we're talking about
the market for car mechanic services as
people have more income they might be
able to afford better cars that are more
reliable that break down less and then
they would have to go to the car
mechanic less and so that situation
where our demand would actually go down
when our income goes up or our percent
change will become negative when we have
a positive percent change in income that
would be that is known as
and inferior good inferior good so
there's two big things to take away one
you don't just have to think about price
elasticity of supply or demand there are
other types of elasticity's but just to
hit the point home on income elasticity
let's look at a few examples so we're
told suppose that when people's income
increases by 20% they buy 10 percent
less fast food in this situation what
type of good would fast food be pause
this video and think about it well their
income is increasing but their demand is
decreasing so that's the situation we
just talked about this is an inferior
good in fear you're good and for kicks
what is the income elasticity of demand
right over here calculate that so just
remember our income elasticity of demand
is just going to be our percent change
in quantity demanded divided by our
percent change instead of price or SI in
income that's right percent change of
income which is going to be what well we
know our percent change in income it
went up by 20 percent in this example
and what happened to our quantity
demanded well it went down by 10 percent
so negative 10 percent and so here you
have an income elasticity of demand of
negative 1/2 or negative 0.5 let's do
another example suppose we knew that
when people's income increased by 5
percent in a country the demand for
healthcare increased by 10 percent what
kind of good do people consider
healthcare normal or inferior so first
calculate the income elasticity of
demand for this example and then answer
these questions all right so first we
are our income elasticity of demand
let's see when our income increases by
5% we have a 5% increase in income our
demand for healthcare in
by 10% our demand for health care
increases by 10% so we get a positive
income elasticity of demand and so in
general if this thing is positive you're
dealing with a normal good as income
goes up then you similar see quantity
demand quantity demanded going up so
this is a normal good